if there's anyone who has not been
thanked by Cuba please just give me your
name she's waiting backstage what a
great moment now to present the award
for best art direction the star of speed
and speed to the only person this room
who's actually ever ridden on an LA city
bus
please welcome Sandra Bullock
movies are illustrated dreams into
paraphrase another Award winner the
Grammys Hillary Rodham Clinton it takes
a village to build a dream and when you
see the credits at the end of the movie
you realize just how vast a village it
took to build that dream from the
blueprints drawn by the art director
there's is a vital discipline that puts
the substance and the make-believe we
call the movies and the nominees for
achievement in art direction are Bois
Welsh captured Miami Beach's razzle and
dazzle in the birdcage with set
decoration by Sheryl Crow assic Stuart
Craig brought back the mystique of Cairo
in the 1940s to his art direction for
the English Patient set decoration was
by Stephanie McMillan
Brian Morris evoked the passion and
dimension of Argentina and its people
and his work for Evita was set
decoration by Philippe to lure Tim
Harvey's scholarly rendering of the sets
for Hamlet brought added Beauty to the
bards masterwork Catherine Martin
working with set decoration by Bridget
Brock filled William Shakespeare's Romeo
and Juliet with dark tragedy and
colourful arenas and the Oscar goes to
Stuart Craig for the English Patient
the nationality of this film is very
complicated but it was made in Italy and
Tunisia and the painted frescoes there
they painted the frescoes and bulldoze
the sand dunes a really accurate
chronology him and to you the Academy
the entire team thank you
you